all we have left to do is evaluate this
integral which is really an exercise in
kind of evaluating trigonometric
integrals more than anything else but it
never hurts to get that practice so
let's just do it step by step so we see
sine cubed theta no obvious way to
directly take the anti-derivative of
sine cubed theta but if we had some
mixtures of sines and cosines there then
we could start
essentially doing u substitution which
at this point you probably can do in
your head so what we could do is we
could write this as a product so we
could write this as sine of theta
so i'll do this part right over here
this is sine of theta
sine of theta times sine squared theta
times sine squared theta and sine
squared theta can be written as one
minus cosine squared theta so this is
the same thing as sine of theta
times
sine of theta times one minus cosine
squared theta and if we multiply this
out this gives us sine theta
sine theta minus
sine
theta
cosine squared theta and this is much
easier for us to integrate although it
looks like a more complicated expression
because it's easy to take the
anti-derivative of sine theta and now
it's easier easy to take the
antiderivative of this because we have
the derivative of cosine theta sitting
right over here so this is going to be
cosine cubed theta over 3. so
essentially we're doing u substitution
right over here but i'll save that for a
second let's rewrite all of these in a
way that's easy to take the
antiderivative of it cosine squared
theta we know this is a common trig
identity that's the same thing as
one-half
this is the same thing as one-half of
one plus cosine of two theta and once
again this is much much easier to take
the anti-derivative of so i'll write
plus
plus i'll write plus one-half plus
one-half
cosine
of
two theta
and now we
all of this is actually quite easy to
take the anti-derivative of and so i'll
just rewrite it again so minus 4 cosine
theta plus 4 cosine theta
sine
theta minus cosine
theta sine squared theta d theta just
was able to sneak it in and so that's
our integral between 0 and 2 pi so let's
just take the anti-derivative and every
one of these steps it's starting to get
a little bit messy i'll try to write a
little bit neater the anti-derivative of
sine of theta is cosine of theta is
negative cosine of theta
negative
cosine of theta if you take the
derivative of cosine theta you get
negative sine theta then the negatives
cancel out you get that right over there
then over here we have the derivative of
cosine theta which is negative sine
theta so we can essentially kind of
treat this we can kind of make the
substitution that u is cosine theta
that's essentially what we're doing in
our head so the anti-derivative of this
is going to be equal to
plus
cosine
cubed theta
over three
and then the anti-derivative of one-half
with respect to theta is going to be
plus
one-half
theta
the anti-derivative of cosine two theta
well we want the derivative of this
thing sitting someplace the derivative
of this thing over here is 2. so if we
put a 2 here we can't just multiply by 2
arbitrarily we'd have to multiply and
divide by 2. so we could put a 2 here
and then we could also but we'd also
have to divide by 2 so then that would
become a 4 and we haven't changed this
notice this is now 2 4 cosine of 2 theta
the exact same thing is one half cosine
2 theta but this is useful because now
the way we've written it here we have
the derivative of 2 theta right over
here and so we can just say well we'll
just take the antiderivative of this
whole thing which is going to be sine of
2 theta but we still have the one so the
antiderivative of this part right over
here is sine of 2 theta and we have the
1 4 out there so plus
1 4
sine of 2 theta
and then the anti-derivative cosine
theta is just sine theta so minus 4 sine
theta minus 4
sine theta antiderivative of this right
over here we can kind of pick whichever
way we want to do it but we could say
well the derivative of sine theta is
cosine theta so this is going to be the
same thing as 4
sine squared theta
sine squared theta over 2
over 2 or instead of saying over 2
instead of writing that 4 i'll just
divide the 4 by the 2 and i will get a
2.
i will get a 2. so let me erase that and
put a 2 right over here and you could
work it out yourself you were to take
the derivative of this thing right over
here would be the derivative of sine
theta if you just use chain rule which
would be cosine theta and then times
times
4
sine of theta so that's exactly what we
have right over here and then we have
this last part
the derivative of sine theta is cosine
theta and so once again just like we've
done before the anti-derivative of this
whole thing is going to be negative
sine
cubed of theta over 3. and we need to
evaluate this entire expression
between 0
0 and 2 pi so let's see how it evaluates
so first let's evaluate everything at 2
pi so this is going to be this evaluated
at 2 pi is negative 1.
this evaluated at 2 pi is 1 3.
this evaluated at 2 pi
is just going to be pi
this evaluated at 2 pi is 0 because sine
of 4 pi is going to be 0 this evaluated
at 2 pi is going to be 0. this evaluated
at 2 pi is going to be 0 and this value
of 2 pi is going to be 0. so that's
that's a nice simplification so that's
everything evaluated at 2 pi and from
that we're going to have to subtract
everything evaluated at 0.
so cosine of 0 well that's going to be
once again 1 and we have a negative sign
so it's negative 1 then you're going to
have plus 1 3 and then you're going to
have 0 and then all these other things
are going to be 0. and so if you
simplify it you get this is going to be
equal to negative 1 plus 1 3
plus pi
plus pi and then we have plus 1
plus 1
minus one-third well that cancels with
that that cancels with that and we
deserve a drum roll now it all
simplified just like when we use stoke's
theorem in like the four videos actually
i think it was a little bit simpler to
just directly evaluate the line integral
over here we got it simplifying to just
pi